dear kitten look at you all grown up
but never mind you're still a child did
you know that I'm a very famous
influencer
humans all around the world watch videos
of me on that box they worship which
means I'm required to tell you what a
day in my life looks like as if you
weren't already watching me all the time
anyway
to start the day I have my morning
Beauty routine nope not their kitten
that's a different kind of video it's
important to clean the humans too they
need it you'd think they don't even have
a tongue next I do my daily workout
this is always a big hit
after another quick clean up I start the
influencing
the key thing is getting the box to
notice you
challenges sometimes work
like how Gary the Chipmunk got famous
for shoving peanuts in his mouth I'm not
saying we do that kitten it's beneath us
remember when you knocked the wine glass
off the little table in the living room
well that would have been a hit but I
find the most success with well looking
adorable
I mean come on the box can't resist that
boom excellent pose kitten remember we
need to keep the Box wanting more so
don't be too easy
after I've posted I like to check out
the competition Fifi does like an outfit
of the day thing I actually don't mind
this the Bell is a nice touch I mean
this one looks just like me it's
annoying oh here's Denise she's trying
to do the whole makeup tutorial thing oh
look at this amateur you're probably
thinking it's good right wrong you don't
want him laughing at you and right there
is not a water bowl you learn the hard
way uh don't go um he's all the way in
it
oh come on this one's just needy get it
this has to be product placement you can
tell the whole thing's set up look at
that fake plant in the back and a star
pillow who has a star pillow
see this is the actual competition
they're adorable both of them it's times
two
you know kitten I think cats are so
popular because humans secretly want to
be us
there was that time she tried to grow
claws or when she puts stripes in her
fur
or how she's always practicing our poses
why no idea but I stopped trying to
understand humans once I saw them shave
their fur finally it's time for my
favorite part of the day
Friskies Seafood Sensations with a treat
of little gravies on top
I just wish I could influence her into
giving me a second helping
and then of course I have my nighttime
routine another successful day
always leave them wanting more
[Music]